okay Louis I have a voicemail to play
this is just insane I don't know how
long this is going to go on we first had
a call from Troy York saying that
there's a conspiracy to put gas stations
in rural areas and cool restaurants in
urban areas then Ramon Ramos called in
it was just Troy you're right and Ramon
Ramos said uh that the exact same thing
basically and we said yeah this is just
Troy York then Troy you're called in and
said I don't know Ramon Ramos that's
someone else of course they have the
exact same boys but I happen to agree
with everything Ramon Ramos said and
then now we have yet another caller who
is calling in it's clearly Troy York and
by the way they agree with both Troy and
Ramon about this issue take a listen hi
David this is Andi Cruz oh I just
wondered if you can maybe have you call
a number be the same when you take phone
calls some people might get confused
with a phone number and and not be able
to have 100 numbers memorized ah I had
to take issue with what you had said
about just two previous callers uh
saying that there is no conspiracy about
um having crept big-box stores all in
the countryside and all your gas
stations and dollar stores and uh and uh
cigarettes doors Dunkin Donuts Exedra
are your corporate crap y'all in a
country where the land is cheap and then
all the heavy investment from foreign
countries and high-end restaurants cafes
jealous all places boutiques being in
the downtown where it's mostly white or
wealthy asian and if you think there's
no conspiracy with that make sure near
is uh uh attract more people to draw in
all right let's cut it I mean it's the
same thing yeah we get it mr. Cruz what
was this guy's first name and this is
Andi Cruz agrees with Troy York who
agrees with Ramon Ramos all who call
from the same block number at basically
the same time of day with the exact same
voice all really interested in this
name hyper niche issue I've never heard
anyone else mentioned is conspiracy yeah
there's not people who ever call talking
about this have the same voice call it
the same time okay I don't know how much
longer we're going up good gonna go on
right i mean if if you you know of uh
whoever David Smith calls next with the
exact same position we might just have
to put an end to it I don't even have
time to tell you what's on the bonus
show today but it's absolutely
tremendous